we'll need to continue importing the gas
because
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after five weeks in oregon
i headed north
toward home
i've come back to washington every
summer for the past six years
it's where i last lived before moving on
to the road
for me the pacific northwest is pure
magic especially in the summer and fall
months before the rain moves in
the days are long the weather is warm
and everything is green
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before meeting up with anna and mariah
and finn on the olympic peninsula i had
mostly been alone for months
even after returning to washington
i pretty much kept to myself
purposefully seeking out places and
situations that
would allow me to continue being alone
if you saw my last video then you know i
was going through some personal stuff
and looking back
i can see now that i did the same thing
i've always done whenever life feels
heavy
i go inward
and i isolate
[Applause]
i do my best to work through problems by
myself until i find the words encouraged
to
convince everyone that i'm okay
[Applause]
if i'm really being honest
i feel uncomfortable leaning on people
especially when i need them the most
[Applause]
i've always felt safest relying on
myself
although with time i found that i could
rely on nature too
nature is simple
it doesn't judge or distance itself
year after year season after season it
shows up for us
trees grow flowers bloom rivers flow
i once read somewhere that we often
forget the small wonders of the world
like the fact that water our collective
lifeline literally falls from the sky
nature gives and nature takes
regardless of who you are
it's reliable like that
it's almost sunset so it's going to be
beautiful beautiful golden light but
as soon as the sun goes down i have to
book it back to camp oh i'm eating my
hair i have to book it back to camp
because
it's a mile and a half
oh it's a mile and a half through really
dark dark forest
and uh there's no light
and there's this is mountain lion
country black bear country so
we're gonna enjoy the sunshine for just
a little bit and then
run
[Music]
[Music]
i thought they were like really sticking
it to you and it's a success yeah right
exactly
there you go
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few days i've been kind of
thinking about i'm like we're doing it
again sitting on the ground
this is a mariah thing i'm convinced
it all it takes is one person
[Laughter]
i love it
my love for the wild is why i moved onto
the road
i like to travel and try new things and
i'm pretty much always down for a good
adventure
but those things alone wouldn't be
enough to outweigh the many obstacles
and lack of stability that comes with
living out of a vehicle
i live this way because it enables me to
spend most of my time outdoors
[Music]
out here there's always a road that will
lead me home
to a quiet place beneath towering
evergreens or somewhere by the sea
below a river of stars or high up on a
canyon ledge
at the foot of a mountain or somewhere
above the clouds
places that are
uncomplicated where there's space to
think and to dream
these are the kinds of places where i
feel safe
safe in a way that i've never really
felt within a home
or with other people
the kind of safety and belonging that
money can't buy
[Music]
there are reasons for that
many of which i'm still discovering and
working through
but over the past couple months i've
timidly stepped into a new reality
a reality that's showing me
just how different life can be when you
let yourself lean into community
[Music]
here's your bowl
your tofu and cucumber and red onion
rice all the good things
[Music]
[Music]
we were down by the river all through
the night watching the stars and the
city lights right from the starts and we
never go apart
[Music]
if you were to ask me how we all came
together i wouldn't even know what to
say
it was a series of strange unlikely and
fortunate events
all of which required small steps of
faith along the way
cheers thank you so much anna
i'm just really stupid grateful for
these two
and for all the beautiful roads that lie
ahead
so as always thank you so much for
watching and
if you follow anna and mariah which if
you don't you definitely should they're
amazing you will know that i'm a little
behind in posting these videos
but
i've been filming a lot and i have some
videos that i'm excited to share with
you all so
thank you for sticking around and if
you'd like to support my channel then
please stay
for today's sponsor love you guys i'll
see you soon
you're finding my foot bro
hi hello quick outbreak
if you guys are like me and you're a
one-person team and you're wearing all
the hats then definitely check out
storyblocks it can save you so much time
by providing access to a curated library
of images overlays templates 4k footage
and pretty much anything you might need
for a commercial or personal project
footage like this for example might take
hours if not days of travel location
scouting requesting permits gear prep
editing and often waiting for the right
conditions just to create this one clip
storyblocks is an affordable
subscription-based website that gives
you access to unlimited downloads of
over 1 million royalty-free stock assets
i personally love the text and overlay
templates because there's so many to
choose from and they're easy to
customize and save for future projects
having access to assets like this means
you spend less time on logistics and
learning complex design programs and
more time doing what you love so be sure
to check them out by visiting this link
in the description below
put me together take me back where i
belong
you